demi lovato deactivates her twitter
account amid backlash over her comments
about 21 savage yeah to back it up a
little bit agents from ice that's
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
arrested the rapper 21 savage on Super
Bowl Sunday saying the british-born
rapper has been in the US illegally for
more than a decade the agency said 21
Savage is a British national and entered
the country legally in 2005 remaining in
the u.s. after his non-immigrant visa
expired a year later so since 2006 ice
claims he's been in the US illegally so
Twitter did its thing and a million
memes and jokes about 21 Savage were
born and Demi kind of joined in tweeting
so far 21 savage memes have been my
favorite part of the Superbowl people
were not happy about this nope nope she
received a lot of really hurtful
comments really she shared this meme
referencing 21 savages British
citizenship with the caption this how 21
Savage be writing his verses and
explained quote fYI this is the dumb
laughing at not the fact that anyone is
getting deported rapper wale weighed in
tweeting why is somebody freedom funny I
don't get the joke while I continued
referring to the fans who supported
Lovato after her overdose last summer
quote a lot of people were sending you
love light prayers etc when people were
making jokes about you at a rough time a
lot of people bless up oh but it did not
and they're not even close
Wally and Lovato then both commented on
this instapoll from the shade room who
documented their Twitter exchange Demi
wrote quote wale just salty I never
replied to his desperate tweets years
ago Wally's response still income
disrespect you still praying for you
Demi I don't take people when they down
go Queen Demi deleted her Twitter
account but she still has Instagram she
posted some of the backlash she had
received after sharing the 21 savage
meme on her story she posted these three
screenshots from her comment section
where people refer to Lovato's overdose
and history of addiction Lovato then
wrote wasn't laughing at anyone getting
deported I know that's not a joke sorry
if I offended anyone but it's no excuse
to laugh at someone's addiction let
alone their OD lastly I wasn't making
fun of anything having to do with
deportation or even anything against him
I was laughing at who the new 21 was
British literally no one that's it it
doesn't go deeper than that
I'm sorry if I upset people truly she
ended her post calling out while a
riding yo at wale if you want to talk
then answer my DMS Lovato was
hospitalized in July 2018 following an
overdose at her Hollywood Hills home she
was in the hospital for nearly two weeks
before being released to seek inpatient
treatment the Disney Channel um first
broke her silence on social media in
August writing quote I have always been
transparent about my journey with
addiction what I've learned is that
illness is not something that disappears
or fades with time it is something I
must continue to overcome and have not
done yet
I want to thank God for keeping me alive
and well to my fans I am forever
grateful for all of your love and
support throughout the past week and
beyond that post has since been deleted
but in January Demi tucked her insta
story to reveal to fans that she's now a
six months sober posting this pic of a
slice of cake from her team along with a
card reading happy six months we are so
proud of you she also shared this pic of
her holding her new sobriety coin so
obviously this is a super complex and
somewhat sensitive story and it's one of
those situations where there's not
really a side we're kind of just rooting
for everyone to win in this case yeah
and it's just reactionary Twitter at its
finest no we just want everyone to be
healthy and happy
mm-hm and of course we're gonna keep you
up-to-date on all the latest news as it
unfold so be sure to subscribe to all
things et until next time I'm at Halle
underscore Stephens and I'm at ash
Crossin bye for now
you
[Music]